the select house committee investigating
the assault on the capitol holds a
hearing today on efforts to push former
vice president mike pence to overrule
the 2020 election results cbs news
confirms the committee has obtained
emails between a lawyer involved in that
effort and conservative activist jenny
thomas she is married to supreme court
justice clarence thomas nicole killian
is on capitol hill nicole good morning
what else do we know about these emails
hey good morning to you nate and
according to sources close to the
committee these emails suggest that
justice thomas's wife could have been
more involved in efforts to overturn the
2020 election than previously known and
the committee is now trying to figure
out whether that should be part of these
public hearings
because if mike pence does the right
thing
we win the election today the select
committee investigating the january 6th
attack will argue the pressure campaign
on former vice president mike pence to
overturn the 2020 election came straight
from the top it all came down in the
final analysis
to
donald trump
and his team
trying to
coerce the vice president of the united
states mike pence into stepping outside
of his constitutional role committee
aides say they'll focus on several
aspects of that scheme starting with a
debunked theory pushed by conservative
attorney john eastman suggesting pence
could block the certification of the
election which pence's aides dismissed
i'll always believe that i did my duty
that day cbs news has confirmed
documents recently reviewed by the
committee found email correspondence
between eastman and jenny thomas the
wife of supreme court justice clarence
thomas as first reported by the
washington post jenny thomas also
exchanged 29 text messages with trump
chief of staff mark meadows about
overturning the election results check
out my flag i made guys see it there you
go buddy wednesday the panel released
new january 6 footage of a man
threatening members of congress as
riders march toward the capitol for
pelosi
nadler
schumer
even you aoc
we're coming to take you out the panel
alleges the individual heard on tape was
at the capitol complex on january 5th he
was seen on surveillance video taking
unusual photos of hallways security and
staircases during a tour led by georgia
republican barry lowdermilk but can you
explain who you were giving a tour to
that day well it was a family and some
guests of folks that they brought from
georgia do you know who that man was
in the video i don't know him do you
think what's on that video is
appropriate absolutely not i condemn
that kind of language
but no one in that group showed that
type of aggression that day
the capitol police say they didn't see
anything suspicious about the tour and
congressman loudermilk says there is
nothing there even though the committee
has spent the better part of the month
trying to get him to answer questions he
claims he never got their request
nate
nicole thank you